d'ailleurs je vous dire j'ai envie de
faire exceptionnellement ce soir
qui balance qui
chacun va balancer un dos sur une
personne sur ses plateaux najam un
tekken henry
ok alors alors guillaume genton
alors bien que moi j'ai laissé que ce
décompte a été prêté dans le mange pas
content j'ai prêté une de mes voitures à
benjamin week end une bourride sur de
sport ça commence par l jeudi par hbo
voilà nîmes a dit est-ce que je peux
t'emprunter ta voiture pour aller
week-end et une boccolini beaucoup de
ces deux de ses voitures n'ont pas le
permis a1 alors il me dit très bien je
prends ta voiture et c'est une petite
pointe à voiture les défoncer faut que
tu arrêtes de la prêter à tes potes moi
j'ai bien m'en occuper c'est super et
c'est moi qui prends la voiture il
m'envoie une photo fièrement sur
l'autoroute en train de rouler très vite
non les quinze minutes plus tard il
m'appelle la voiture défoncée non
non il pas bon et pour vous prouver que
ça devient dur que ça va être pour vous
prouver que c'est un ignoble mito dans
l'émission il était venu avec des avec
des bandelettes xinjian me suis fait je
me suis fait mal avec mon grip en
juillet
donc la voiture est morte en a arrêté la
voiture est morte je paie une assurance
une blinde ils me remercient moi tu es
une nouvelle voiture grâce à moi
avec la voiture pour la paix ni la mère
fait ces voitures ne tient pas la route
non
ça coûte très cher et vraiment c'est bon
de la merde et en plus il sait que s'il
ya un mois il m'avait demandé de lui
prêter une voiture j'ai fait ce que je
répondu non tout va bien je suis tout en
ville où
il a mis en fait il ya il avait neigé
ses looks ému il a neigé sur notre jean
milési et donc des abonnés sur le bas
côté non
c'est vrai je vous donnais des photos
des voitures
ministre qui met un peu de neige et
comme ces vautours ne tiennent pas la
route
j'ai à combien non non je n'ai pas la
preuve que je n'allais pas du tout ce
que je n'ai je n'ai rien eu du tout j'ai
même pas été baissé rien à la voiture
s'en souvient elle va mal à outre les
morts lui a choisi entre vous et la
voiture et de jeudi la voiture est en
fait et en fait j'ai mordu un petit peu
sur la neige et là je suis parti en tête
à queue non ah oui et j'ai fait un coup
à droite un coup à gauche un coup à
droite un coup à gauche voiture
j'ai tapé et l'avant et derrière et le
côté droit
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de savon au bout du doigt la
paix j'aime leur festin j'ai regardé une
bonne surprise
elina duni tu marie dit quoi j'ai pu
attaquer sa marraine oui
mais moi mais serez témoin mais
on est assuré les assiettes pas d'avoir
de dommages corporels
je ne s'occupe de
rien mais gentil savait déjà mais c'est
un amour et bio il a dit quoi non non il
est dit qu'il était très cool en fait ça
l'arrangé pas
rassuré il a été remplacé au prix du
neuf et il faudrait que moi tant il est
mature fuchsia avec un prime d'assurance
par mois oui mais il ne conduit pas
grave tu n'as pas le permis non mes
tripes d'assurance par ma réaction et là
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quand même
une petite rancoeur
si vous l'avez retraités way a jamais
non fourni là il m'a donc je vous le dis
autour de la table ne prêtez jeunes et
nature à bagdad est prêté ouais jamais
si vous a ramené des radars sauvent
n'est pas si c'est vrai c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
xd j'ai pu ni les radars ah bah oui moi
je sais qu'après
72 ou le samedi ça va ouais bah oui non
vitré terlain non je vous dis non mais
si tu as aimé vélo par exemple pas non
mais non mais non mais je pourrais même
pas mon slip
voilà voilà alors tu es content oui je
très content et les lentilles ont parlé
de la soirée de gens
savent bien le lendemain de l'action il
va quand même proposé d'acheter une
voiture etc lui tu découpes j'ai
réfléchi avec les équipes sont derrière
toi la barre était encore alors
sera-t-il et s'ouvrira aussi sur
quelqu'un
sur vous
[Applaudissements]
ah les annulations
quelle séquence de même
auquel s'est quant à
lui alors parfois nous vous convoquer
dans votre loge way pour faire un petit
point un petit brief comme ça et à
chaque fois je remarque qu'il ya une
odeur étrange
à bâle lui à base d'huiles essentielles
oui faut savoir c'est pour dissimuler
quoi exactement alors je vous dis non
pas du tout c'est que je suis que vous
avez nommés
je vous jure que c'est vrai que là vous
êtes des microbes
c'est vrai et à sept mois qui viennent
lafarge en mai par m mais c'est moi vous
arrivez dans ma loge c'est à bâle à vous
est désinfecté vous ressortez c'est
harpic bienvenue dans l'autre la pub oui
moi j'ai une autre question parce que
par vous nous convenons en attendant
chacun un dossier par dossier justement
non mais on n'est pas sûr d'aller en
dons et sur les monts
vous déjà bravo pour le nubuck
vraiment ça là il serait très belles
saillies alors ouais nous abonde soul
non non vous ne regardez pas
tard acheter des vidéos car texas en
baisse tout faire
c'est un dossier tout sur quelqu'un moi
j'ai pas de dossier c'est peut-être une
confession mais pas de dossier à une
confession intime ouais confessions
intimes mais toi
moi j'ai chiné delphine sur instagram
attendez attendez sinon les gens à
envoyer les chevaux j'ai tout envoyé
comme benjamin un tête à queue et
honnêtes a envoyé des jouets ben on voit
des joueurs pas des voitures
[Applaudissements]
chiner des futurs instagram qui ont
besoin de fécamp quant à ya d'autres
choses à faire au moins trois quatre
mois quand elle sait public
mais c'est
vraiment toi pourquoi et parce que c'est
fort à le dire déjà assez fort d'y
croire m
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est pas moi je vais
finir chauffeur libre voir quand même de
même je me suis alors alors donc ça
c'est beau mais là je parlais de la
veste
verte et malin c'est que je me suis
comme à fait pu l'émission elle voit
plus personne je vais passer sur le côté
mais oui mais oui parce que l'on raconte
la wii je suis là alors c'est quoi ça a
était quoi la finale sur la chine bon
sur un sherpa une photo cas là du match
j'ai largué après le mar est pendu sur
un truc comment tu vas et moi faut pas
me dire comment je vois
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mangé des cailloux toute ma vie à
fouiller à miss france qui me demande
comment je vais
et partir j'en vois trois coeurs direct
non
trois comme
elle est sympa leur voyage non on n'a
pas renvoyé par hajnal a juste dit
allait rester très très courtois elle
m'a dit go courtois j'en sais rien mais
m'a dit oui ça va bien et où j'y suis
t'ennuies paella est là lui dit elle lui
dit comment ça va bien et là lui et
parents will envoie une aubergine merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit que la femme du bas rien je
kiffe fort boyard est là en fait encore
attendre je rebascule producteur serait
bien que tu reviens dans l'émission tu
manques année
cette commande a dit c'est ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
votre
choix il est pas content bon tu es bête
je suis en très bonne position et
delphine la non montée dans les sondages
je crois pas utile
dans les haies dans les seaux d'eau du
lac d'annecy nous fait une marine le pen
eric zemmour qui laisse en rien n'abat
julie alors alors vas-y donc pour
l'instant pour moi c'est raymond qui
monte dans les rues parce que le
producteur allemand calais mission
d'apporter quelque chose de bien tu
avais des bonnes analyses et c'est ce
que je pense et ce que je pense toujours
d'ailleurs et me dit oui mais c'était
c'est le papa de delphine rouget enfin
avec
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est rien parce qu'il est en gsm
oui c'est ask voilà donc johnny et
tiberi il
donc apparemment il était il à côté
d'une banque voilà comme ça mais il
faudrait que tu reviennes si on
proposait de revenir dit oui mais faudra
que ce soit un peu plus différent enfin
que je parle plus je m'inquiète pas je
voir ce que je peux faire
[Applaudissements]
légère
hausse c'est l'intervention à vous le
courage
l'audace eux d'assurer le das le bas
c'est toi la mythomane
ou parce que le gars ne m'a jamais parlé
donc pas tout gagné je me documente jeu
[Applaudissements]
après deux journées je me lève le matin
je n'ai jamais vu en parler mais non
mais non mais oui d'accord mais les
choses se sont faites
et les choses se sont faites parce qu'en
fait on a tu vois ces débats retransmis
français on sait qu'il a fait une
question mais je veux tu seras pas
est-ce que tu avais vu est-ce que tu
avais senti que raymond taux plancher
non
non non non mais c'est un truc de ouf et
mes coups droits bien mais elle sait à
prix doux ça veut dire il faut vraiment
que vraiment que ça se passe vraiment
après quoi ces voix-là delphine qui ne
c'est un truc que c'est le mec est en
train de la galoche
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais prévu que moi je ne vois pas le
mal et je n'y avais pas dire banale à
l'allemagne
c'est vrai moi je suis jamais dans la
séduction en fait je ne cherche pas j'ai
pas les visées à pour safari oui parce
que j'ai pas besoin quand est ce que
quand je t'ai parlé ça t'as pas fait
revenir à des missions est malade il
y croit j'appris invention un statut
protégé à l'émail quant à lui de poser
la question je suis allé un peu mais
c'était quand
est-ce que tu as senti voulait de pécho
banon mais non ça du tout pratique en
plus moi j'en vois beaucoup de coeur
rouge par exemple ils sont hyper c'est
toi bien moindre soin coeur rouge tu vas
te dire tout de suite eu là bas
il reçoit que rouge il appelle la
synagogue
[Rires]
on
voit pas de coeur sec les uns avaient
sur youtube l'envoie à coeur
demandent un service ne lui envoie
jamais d'abricots
parce que l'aubergine à bricoler ces
voix là c'est noté c'est plutôt
compliqué vous avez décroché un certain
c'est qu'on parle
des fois d'accord parler d'aubergines a
envoyé un abricot oui
normes abricots les briques rouges le
razz
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous mettre la fonction abricots
séchés de rethel
[Applaudissements]
bon bah c'est le seul de l'équipe qui le
hantent j'aimerais bien voila j'aimerais
bien que delphine à nous disent un jour
tous et qui viennent là aussi super
marrant carrière parce que toi tu vois
pas le mal il ya donné à d'autres qui
doivent envoyer des messages kassali
pour qu'ils gardent la tête
[Applaudissements]
je ris castanet et la publ c'est le père
lucas toni
est ce que ça va me tomber dessus
delphine la question aller simple bah
oui il ne répond pas est ce que au sein
de l'établissement
oui ou non
d'autres messages que toi tu ne vois pas
comme des messages de branges
attitude ou devant douchez bon vous
savez à quel point c'est vrai on le dit
récemment que j'ai une belle relation
avec guillaume content maintenant qu'on
parle des fruits et légumes
[Rires]
en crise et moselle et j'avais jamais
fait le lien parce que moi je vois pas
ces choses là que tu m'envoies très
souvent dézoné soirée
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît tu veux mais pour les
amateurs de cuisine ça c'est que ce
n'est pas pour faire une moussaka
oui parce que je suivais gagnent ouais
c'est sûr et gagnent donc on échange
souvent autour des fruits et légumes tu
te fous de la gu photos dans la galerie
en défaveur de la gueule du monde encore
longtemps je devais y demeure une
question pour delphine être honnête j'ai
été un peu outré par les propos de
raymond soeur qui l'a draguée comme un
crevard sur sur la faille albertine est
ce que tu préfères mois ou l'abominable
homme de rungis raymond
[Applaudissements]
ne rentrez pas là dedans
et delphine vous nous ferez d'autres
révélations j'espère bientôt oui vous
regardez quelqu'un j'ai l'impression à
gauche
non je suis extrêmement serein bah oui
vraiment c'était le voit d'ailleurs
des liens non non mais non mais non non
non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà alors
merci merci à les bonbons on en saura la
vérité demain